it's clear that we live in an age of
pathological
short-termism our politicians can barely
see past the next election
or even the latest tweet businesses
can't see past the next quarterly report
markets spike then crash in speculative
bubbles nations sit around
international conference tables focused
on their near-term interests
while the planet burns and species
disappear
and as individuals we're constantly
answering the latest text and clicking
the buy now button
this is the age of the tyranny of the
now
and it's obvious i think that we need
long-term thinking to deal with this
tyranny of the now we need it to do
long-term planning and public health
care
to get ready for the next pandemic that
might be on the horizon
we need it to tackle racial injustice
that gets passed on from generation
to generation embedded in criminal
justice systems
and cultural institutions more broadly
we need it to
prepare us for technological risks such
as the risks from ai controlled lethal
autonomous weapons
and of course we need long-term thinking
to help us confront
the challenge of the climate crisis
biodiversity loss
soil degradation our addiction to fossil
fuels
and there's a kind of paradox here which
is that the need for long-term thinking
is incredibly urgent we need it right
here
right now and the way i think about this
is that i believe that
humankind has colonized the future
we treat the future like a distant
colonial outpost where we can
freely dump ecological degradation
and technological risk as if there was
nobody
there and it's a bit like the way when
britain colonized australia in the 18th
and 19th century they drew on a legal
doctrine
now known as terra nullius nobody's land
they treated the continent
as if there were no indigenous people of
course they were
and i think today what we've also got
alongside terenalis is
tempus nullius the future is seen
as nobody's time an uninhabited
territory
that is ours for the taking and the
tragedy
is that tomorrow's generations aren't
here to challenge this pillaging of
their inheritance
they can't leap in front of the king's
horse like a suffragette
or stay just sit in like a civil rights
activist or go an assault march to defy
their colonial oppressors
like mahatma gandhi the grant had no
political rights or representation
they have no influence at the
marketplace the great silent majority of
future generations
is rendered powerless but it can be very
difficult to grasp
the scale of this injustice so look at
it this way
there are 7.7 billion people alive today
now over the past 50 000 years an
estimated
100 billion people have been born and
died
but both of these are far outweighed by
the nearly 7
trillion people who will be born over
the next 50 000 years
assuming current birth rates stabilize
so there in that giant orange circle
are all your grandchildren and their
grandchildren
and the friends and communities on whom
they'll depend
and i think the question that really
matters is how are those future
generations
going to judge us for what we did or
didn't do
when we had the chance